[Music]
in 1943 Allied aircraft swooped over
Nazi Germany rainin tens of thousands of
leaflets on people below written by
anonymous Germans the leaflets urge
readers to renounce Hitler to fight
furiously for the future and to never
give up hope
their call to action rippled through
homes and businesses and news of their
message even reached concentration camps
and prisons it was only after the war
had ended that the author's identities
stories and tragic fate would come to
light when Hitler seized power ten years
earlier hans and sophie scholl
were teenagers in the town of Falkenburg
at that time fear propaganda and
surveillance kept all aspects of life
for the Scholl family and millions of
other Germans under Nazi control the
government specifically targeted young
people setting up institutions to
regulate their behavior and police their
thoughts as teenagers Hans was a member
of the Hitler Youth and Sophie joined
the League of German girls
Hans rose through the ranks and oversaw
the training and indoctrination of other
young people in 1936 he was chosen to
carry the flag at a national rally but
when he witnessed the zeal of Nazi
rhetoric he began to question it for the
first time meanwhile Sophie was also
starting to doubt the information she
was being fed their parents Robert and
Magdalena who had feared they were
losing their children to Nazi ideology
encourage these misgivings at home
Robert and Magdalena listened to foreign
radio stations the government first
discouraged and later banned
while the government turned out national
broadcasts which denied Nazi atrocities
the shawls learned shocking truths and
yet they were still subject to the rules
of life in Hitler's Germany after the
outbreak of war so if you reluctantly
worked for the national effort and Hans
had to take on army duties while
attending medical school in Munich
that was where Hans met Christoph
Provost Villa Graf and Alexander morale
day by day each grew more sickened by
Nazi ideology they longed to share their
views but how could they spread them
when it was impossible to know who to
trust
and so the friends decided to rebel
anonymously they pooled their money and
bought printing materials an
acquaintance let them use a cellar under
his studio in secret they began drafting
their message in June 1942 mysterious
anti-nazi leaflets began appearing all
over Munich they were signed the White
Rose the first leaflet denounced Hitler
and called for Germans to sabotage the
war effort adopt passive resistance
blocked the functioning of this
atheistic war machine before it is too
late before the last city is a heap of
rubble before the last youth of our
nation bleeds to death don't forget that
each people gets the government it
deserves at a time when a sarcastic
remark could constitute treason this
language was unprecedented it was
written mostly by Hans Scholl in 1942
Sophie came to Munich knowing nothing of
her brother's activities she soon
encountered the leaflets at school but
it was not until she discovered evidence
in honza's room that she realized who'd
written them her shock soon gave way to
resolve she wanted in for both siblings
it was time to escalate the fury that
had been brewing for years
from June 1942 to February 1943 the
group worked feverishly while the
Gestapo search for leaves the white rose
were constantly on guard the war raged
on regulations tighten and Munich
suffered air raids but the White Rose
ventured deeper into conspiracy they
graffiti buildings and braved trains
swarming with gestapo in the winter of
1942 hans made a treacherous journey to
the Czechoslovakian border to meet
anti-nazi rebels On February 18th 1943
Sophie and Hans brought a suitcase of
leaflets to their University a custodian
noticed what they were doing and
reported them to the Gestapo both calmly
denied any involvement until the police
gathered all the leaflets and placed
them back in the empty case where they
fit perfectly when Hans and Sophie
confessed they were immediately led to
court and sentenced to death by
guillotine despite a grueling
interrogation the two refused to betray
their co-conspirators before her
execution Sophie declared her fury at
the state of her country but she also
spoke to a more hopeful future how can
we expect righteousness to prevail when
there is hardly anyone willing to give
himself up individually to a righteous
cause such a fine sunny day and I have
to go but what does my death matter if
through us thousands of people are
awakened and stirred to action
ever wonder how Hitler rose to power in
the first place find out with this video
or for more gut-wrenching bravery and
subterfuge
check out this lesson on Harriet Tubman
liberator of enslaved people's and
secret General in the Union Army
[Music]